that morning we had a big party in lab
and a lot of reporters came to get
comments from people at Harvard um I
think that I'm really excited and
because at high vote however it has a
lot of private funding and and so it's
so some labs that have projects with
less dependent on federal funding but i
think that lots of people in the US
there's thousands of universities many
of which have very bright people trying
to advance stem cell research and that
blockading federal money to those
laboratories really hurts us a lot
because we can't hope to bring Q's into
market I think by just having pilot
funding to universities and corporate
funding for pharmaceuticals and that i'm
really excited now that our current
president is looking forward to trying
to jumpstart stem cell research and
biomedical research as a whole and i
think that as this money gets spread
around the country that we will see a
lot of people from different
universities and institutions publishing
a lot of good work that's really going
to move us forward i'm really excited
that this is going on
I think that while the first FDA trials
clinical trials for stem cells are going
on now with spinal cord injury that many
of my colleagues and friends and I agree
that it will be decades before this
becomes a more prevalent trend and I
think that looking at the current
current drugs for pharmaceutical
companies it can take maybe on a scale
of 10 years and a billion dollars to get
a drug all the way to market and so I
think that means that for the stem cell
studies are being done it now in mice
that it will take at least at the very
minimum a decade Oh much more to be able
to get those two humans I think the fact
is we're so comfortable with taking
pills or taking shots but when gene
therapy came around no one was too
excited about putting viruses into the
body and I think that right now people
aren't too thrilled about putting stem
cells with stem cell-derived cells into
someone's body and I think that it's
really important that we try to take
this slow and be careful and make sure
that nothing that we does can ultimately
harm a person that these stem cells
won't hurt anyone and I think it
definitely will take decades and I guess
maybe as my generation gets older we'll
see some cells come around because
there's a big interest in them and lots
of people interested but I think that
it's something in the new and
foreseeable future but not but
definitely not now and that the future
was definitely going to bring a lot and
I'm really excited to see how it
you